- C'est sans équivoque :
la vaccination contre la COVID
s'essouffle au Québec.
- Moi j'ai seulement trois doses
par contre, mais je trouve que
c'est suffisant pour moi.
- J'en ai eu deux puis je ne
m'en fait pu donner d'autres.
Ça fait deux fois que je pogne
le COVID pareil.
Dr ALEX CARIGNAN, microbio.-
infectio., CIUSSS Estrie-CHUS,
- Il n'y a certainement pas
une urgence à lancer, je dirais,
une grande campagne à travers
le Québec pour tous les gens.
- Les experts s'entendent : les
doses successives de rappel sont
probablement chose du passé
pour la popula g g générale.
Dr KARL WEISS,  prés. Asso.
médecins microbio. infectio., Qc
- Pour les gens qui ont déjà
reçu deux doses de vaccin ou
trois doses de vaccin et pour
ceux qui en plus ont fait
la COVID, la chance que vous
finissiez à l'hôpital avec une
maladie sévère est quasiment
nulle.
- Moi je pense que le virus est
encore présent. La preuve c'est
que beaucoup de gens consultent
à l'hôpital.
- Même pour les 65 ans et plus
en bonne santé qui ont reçu
quatre ou cinq doses, la
vaccination deviendra peut-ê
annuelle dans un futur
rapproché.
Dr ALAIN LAMARRE, professeur
immunologie, virologie, INRS
- D'ajouter comme ça à chaque
cinq, six mois une d d d dose
apporte seulement un bénéfice
marginal.
- Les experts soutiennent que
les personnes plus vulnérables,
immuno-supprimées ou très âgées
devront cependant corrrr
à être protégées.
- Ce sont eux qui se trouve
actuellement sont sous vaccinés
ausse e e e sont eux qu'on peut
réellement protéger avec des
doses de rappel plus fréquentes.
- C'est une bonne nouvelle
pour ceux qui en veulent pas,
puis qui croient, on va dire,
pas à d'autres choses,
mais qui pensent que leur
èèèème immunitaire est assez
fort pour combattre tout ça.
Dans mon cas, ça a été le cas.
- Par contre, pour ceux qui
n'ont jamais été vacciné, ou qui
n'ont jamais attrapé la COVID,
une dose de vaccin demeure
recommandée.
- Ces gens-là sont plus à risque
de complications.
- Pour ce qui est du variant
XBB.1.5 qui frappe les États-
Unis, le Dr  s s s s s'en fait
pas trop.
- On ne devrait pas à mon sens
paniquer chaque fo
nouveau variant arrive,
si vous voulez, dans notre
environnement.
- Les recommandations finales
du Comité sur l'immunisation du
Québec devraient être dévoilées
d'ici une dizaine de jours.
Ce sera ensuite au gouvernement
de décider si oui ou non
les citoyens seront appelés
ou non à recevoir une autre dose
de vaccin.
Ici Pierre-Alexandre Bolduc,
Radio-Canada, Québe